Hey, I'm Jad Abumrad. Hi, I'm Robert
Krulwich. This is radio lab and today
we begin on a plane. Thank you Brooke,
which carried our newly married
producer Tim Howard to the Galapagos.
So I took the plane from Quito.
We had just finished the
honeymoon that morning.
They make announcements and the
certain point, the flight attendants,
they open up all of the overhead bins
and they walk up and down spraying some
sort of insecticide for what? For like uh,
invasive species I think. Yeah,
like whatever bugs might've
snuck on in the brain.
But at this point I'm
getting super excited and I'm
thinking about Darwin and I
start reading voyage of the Beagle,
his book on this nook that
I had bought for the trip,
but then my power supply
didn't work and my nook died.
Does a big problem for Darren to
run out of power. His book. Oh God.
And then the islands come into site.
What is the color of the Pacific Ocean
when you look up the plane window?
That was actually the first thing
I noticed. It's this totally wild,
like I've never seen like
this story book, blue,
green iridescent aqua marine
and I'm thinking like, wow,
this is going to be like dropping
into another world, you know,
like nature and its purest form.
My version was is my dream and what it
would be like is you landed on it and
it's sort of like low grassy knoll
and an enormous turtle comes by.
The one that you could sit on the top of
it and it wouldn't notice that you were
there just going to meet to the airport
just wandering by and basically that's
very similar to what I was
picturing, but maybe we need to land,
we take the 40 minute
bus ride to play for Yara
or Toyota, which turns out
to be kind of a big town.
Tons of people live there. It's
like a fishing village. Tons. No,
it's way bigger than a fishing village.
And just let me say that my first hours
in Galapagos were totally different than
I was expecting.
I'm sort of the first thing that
really just like, where the hell am I?
I am walking through the towns kind
of late Sun is just starting to set me
actually walking down to
Charles Darwin Avenue,
just kind of getting the lay of
the land. When all of a sudden
[inaudible] this line of cars
comes around the corner honking,
endless honking and they're waving flags,
blue flags. At first I didn't
know what that was happening,
but turns out it was an election
and I was just really blown away that
this continued this procession for like 15
minutes.
And I remember asking him one guy on
the up though, they're driving so slow,
I can just walk up to them and say,
I'm, I've got it. Oh, I sold a car.
I'm like, who's your
candidate? And they're like,
I didn't know who the guy was,
but it turns out he was the incumbent
and I'm like, fucking it up.
Is he going to win? And this guy
he like doesn't even say anything.
He just kind of points you like points
at the cars in front and behind as if
like, dude, seriously. You
see how many of us there are?
But then at a certain point I noticed
this one guy by himself standing on the
sidewalk wearing a white shirt
and jeans. He's waving a flag,
but his flag is a different color.
It's white and it's really loud.
But I go up to him and I yell at him,
who is your candidate? And he said,
I am a candidate. And I'm
like, what are you seriously?
So his name is Leon
[inaudible] [inaudible]
he is a naturalist guide.
You actually ended up meeting a lot of
people employed that way in Galapagos and
he tells me so old, so young, outsider,
politically, politically speaking,
he's an outsider.
And of course I'm wondering why he's
standing there by himself waving a flag at
this entire parade of people who don't
support him at all. And he tells me,
cl Momento I'm nervous.
[inaudible] if the party in power now
the front runners, if they get elected,
they will
[inaudible] [inaudible] and I
see a dark and uncertain future.
Grand Hotel is more big hotels,
more of these enormous boats,
more people [inaudible] if
things keep going this way,
who's going to stand up for nature?
This is Radiolab and we are dedicating
the entire hour to this little set of
islands. And to that question,
as the world is filling up with
more and more and more people,
is it inevitable that
even the most sacred,
pristine places on the planet
will eventually get swallowed up?
And how far are we willing to go to return
a place to what it was before we got
there? And more importantly, can we,
oh, I'm never a doubter.
Okay, so this is Linda.
Linda Caio currently the science
advisor for Galapagos Conservancy.
I began my work in Galapagos in 1981
she first came to study tortoise's.
Back then, you know,
Galapagos was really isolated,
barely any cars, super
limited electricity.
All I remember is having a smile on
my face all the time because you know,
as a biologist going to
Galapagos is like going to Mecca.
[inaudible]
she says you have islands with
massive volcanoes, forests,
tree ferns that grow, you know,
well above a human's height.
Yeah, I mean powerful. You know, there's
green mangroves, baklava
flows and pink flamingos.
This is Mateus Espinosa, a
naturalist guide in the Galapagos.
And like Linda, he says that when he
first got to the Galapagos in the 80s,
he couldn't believe that the place
was real to his breast taken.
He visited an island called
if an Andina and the first thing that
I saw was a lava fluid was moving.
I said, what's going on? You No,
no, no, that's lava throws her leg.
1000 CE Guan as taking a sunbath
and he says he would go on these dive.
Can you imagine
schools of hammerhead sharks like 508
tendent passing in front of you like tuna?
I mean like, like sardines.
It shows you the power.
It shows your old for evolution. There
is where evolution is very strong.
Okay, so quick context, uh, Galapagos
islands, cluster of islands,
way off the coast of Ecuador in
the Pacific, 19 bigger islands,
bunch of smaller ones. And this
is the place, of course, we're,
Darwin landed in 1835 and
as he went island to island,
he started noticing that there were all
these creatures that were really similar
to each other, but also
a little bit different.
The tortoise's had different shells
depending on the kind of island they lived
on. The finches look similar,
but their peaks were always a little bit
different. And this gets him thinking,
what if it isn't the way
that everybody always says?
What if God didn't create every single
species in the beginning and leave them
unchanged? What if in fact
life is purely change?
What if everything has
been changing all the time?
Darwin's five weeks on Galapagos pushed
him to develop his theory of evolution.
And that's also why when
we think of evolution,
we think of the Galapagos
and in particular
we think of two iconic
creatures, the tortoise
and the fence.
Let me start by telling you about
the tortoise. It's hot, it's bright.
It's such a perfect day for
tortoise. Something are not hunting.
But you know, looking for
fourth day I was there, um,
I went to the island of Floriana,
which Darwin visited and they're up in
the highlands basically in the middle of
this yard. Oh my God.
There are these three massive tortoises
just clustered together under a tree.
Wow. That is fricking amazing.
Describe them. What are they look like?
These are such alien looking creatures.
They are like the size of, Geez,
I don't even know what they're massive.
They look like they
would crush you to death.
Well now how many years these
guys have been here for?
They can live for over 150
years. Wow. This is a tour.
It is trying to get over a branch.
[inaudible]
who is that? That is a
sound of a tortoise breathe.
That's cool.
So Linda,
when she first went to Galapagos to
study these torts is about 30 years ago.
I did a trip where we
backpacked around the Caldera.
She took a trip to this island called
Isabella hiked up the side of a volcano
and looked at all the tortoise country
and it was an impenetrable forest,
basically tortoise heaven.
And what makes it so perfect for tortoises
is in the dry season in Galapagos
that go Roula, which is a very, very
thick mist, comes onto the island.
It rolls over this forest and it
catches in the branches of the tree.
The water then drips down from the
top of the trees down to the ground.
Creating what we call drip pools,
which provides tortoises with water during
the dry season and they like to rest
in water.
And so there under the trees you have
these ponds with dozens of tortoise domes
just rising out of the water.
So that was my first experience. It
was a magical, magical area. And then,
um,
I actually didn't get back there for
maybe 15 years from when I was there the
first time.
And when I returned that
forest was 100% gone.
The drip pools were just
dry dust bowls. Wow.
There was no shade tortoises where
we're sitting out in the sun or,
or crowded around the couple of
stalks that were still there.
This is Carl Campbell.
I work for island conservation and I'm
based here in the Galapagos Islands.
Carl was actually the guy who showed me
those tortoises. It was just a, yeah,
it was a barren landscape.
Yeah. Barren, barren grounds.
What happened to the
forest? Um, goats. Goats.
And that was definitely not what
I thought you were going to say.
I thought you were gonna say people,
it was kind of a collaboration.
So here's the story.
Goats were originally sort of
brought to the Galapagos, um,
probably by pirates and wireless
back in the 15 hundreds.
You had tons of sailors making these,
these long voyages across the Pacific.
And uh, Galapagos was
the, a, the major port on,
on the wailing route and where,
yeah, you'd come and get fresh water,
but you'd also come in and pick up a
tortoise's land tortoises and Yang boats
and take away several hundred of them
often and turn them upside down and they
can last for up to a year and a
half in the whole of the ship. Like
lying there upside down. Yeah,
lying there upside down in order
to make space for the tortoise's.
The whalers and pirates would often take
goats that they'd brought with them and
throw them onto the islands.
That way when they're on their way
back and sick of eating tortoises,
they could grab those goats.
So whalers and Buccaneers,
they introduced goats to Galapagos.
But on islands like Isabella,
which is this massive
island size of Rhode Island,
the goats were actually penned in to just
a little part of it because there was
this black lava rock that
ran across the island,
[inaudible] rough lava that's extremely
difficult to walk across 12 miles of it.
So that had acted as a barrier basically
with goats on one side toward us on the
other. But according to Linda,
some time in the late
1970s the goats got brave.
We were probably talking just a few goats.
Bye.
The 1990s those few goats,
the population had exploded. And
you need about 100,000 to go.
And if you think of 100,000 goats
eating everything in their path,
every sort of plant, even the bark
off of trees, they destroy the forest.
So now they had a dilemma. On the
one hand, the tortoise's needed help.
On the other hand,
you had all of these goats that didn't
choose to be on the island. You know,
it wasn't their fault. And the goats
that were out there were gorgeous.
You know, they had curled horns,
different colored for just beautiful
animals and they'd been there for 500
years.
Some people were concerned, you know,
with the goats have their own sort of,
if you will, right to be there.
Those arguments came up frequently
to which Carl would respond. Yeah.
Are we going to let
tortoise's go extinct? Yeah.
There's thousands of islands around
the world that have goats on them.
These tortoises are only found
here. So where do your values lie?
[inaudible]
and so in 1994 we had what we called the
tortoise summit in England and that was
where we started the discussions
about what are we gonna do?
Experts came from all over
the world. Linda says,
we want to get rid of the goats.
And many of them thought we were
nuts and that it was impossible.
There's 100,000 of them. So many doubters.
Carl says he even heard the idea,
why don't you put lines?
Yeah, they eat goats in Africa. You
know, why don't you get lions on there?
And those are, you know,
really interesting ideas.
But at some point they're going to get
hungry and they're going to start eating
all the other things that yeah, you
treasure by the occasional tourist.
In any case, after endless planning
and meetings took eight years,
I think they commence
project Isabella,
so the helicopters we used,
they're called MD five hundreds small
helicopter there for four passengers with
one pilot, single turbine, five blades.
This is Frasier Fraser Sutherland.
I was the engineer pilot and a sharp
shooter 2004 through to 2006 almost every
day. During that time Frazier
would fly over Isabella island.
Two guys were two shooters are
the side of the helicopter.
What you do is so you come across and
you're flying along and you might see one
guy says, you follow that go as
it ran away till join his friends.
Do you have to find all those
other guides? Circle of real low.
You'd fly around them, around them up,
try and get them in a single group,
and then
you start picking off the
goats one by one by one.
And there are actually videos online
where you see these packs of goes
running for their lives and
then dropping to the ground.
The last goat or two might sort of run
into a area where it's impossible to
read.
I would actually go into caves and what
we'd do is we'd find a location as close
as we could or right on top of the cave,
drop out one of the two shooters that
was in the helicopter and he'd physically
go into the cave, shoot the goats out,
or shoot them on site.
And then you go on and actually in
under a year through this aerial attack,
they end up wiping out 90%
of the goats on Isabella.
But to give an example of the nature
of this business, that's Josh Donlin,
he runs an NGO that was
involved in project Isabella.
It's relatively easy to remove 90%
of a goat population from an island.
But as they become rare and rare,
they're harder and harder to detect.
The goats become quote, educated.
They learn that this sound yeah
means
so the goats start hiding.
So they'll go onto bushes,
they won't move to learn to stand
under a tree, holding their breath.
And so you end up flying around and
an expensive helicopter not fighting.
And it goes. Now the way we deal
with that, it's an interesting one.
We use this technique
called Judas goats. Yeah,
Judas codes. Initially it was
Carl suggestion, buzz goats, uh,
a gregarious and like being in groups.
They're herd animals, right? And so,
uh, the technique that we would use was
fire up your helicopter. You fly around,
he'd find some, go to capture goats,
capture them, lie, and then
come back back to base camp,
offload them and
put a radio collar on him and
you throw him back on the island
and then you wait.
Instinctively that lone guy will
go and find out the goats a week.
Two weeks go by, you
fire up the helicopter,
they get back over to the
island with this little device,
it's a directional antenna.
Start Tracking the Judas go till they
spot it with some other goats and then
everyone gets shot except
the Judas go. They let it go,
finds more friends,
and then everyone gets shot except the
Judas go and then they do it again.
Everyone gets shot except the Judas
go. And you do that about every
two weeks for a year. Oh my God.
And that is how they go from 90% go free
to 91 to 92 to 93 to 94 [inaudible].
It's like having a pogrom on you
over and over and over again. Jesus.
It gets worse. Now Judas,
Skoda is a good Judas go until it gets
pregnant because then it doesn't want to
be social anymore. It goes off and
has this kid and is very solitary,
which is the last thing you want when
you're trying to get goats off islands.
So Carl kept mulling this problem.
What would it take to basically make,
you know, the perfect year disco,
the Ideal Judas Code, if you will,
um,
is it goat that would search for and be
searched for and that would never get
pregnant.
So Carl Campbell figured out a technique
where we could sterilize them in the
field. It grabbed the goats stardom
and then in a matter of minutes,
SnipSnap did you do this? Yeah. Well, I,
I stood next to Carl and watched him do it
and Carl took it one step further and
he actually gave these females hormone
implants, basically put them into
heat for an extended duration.
Normally a female goat would be in
heat for maybe a couple of days.
These females would go for more than
190 days. And wherever they went,
they would lower those male goats out
of their caves. So that, you know,
all in all over the course
of this two year program,
we had hundreds of Judas goats
out. And using those goats,
they were able to go from 94%
goat free to 96 to 97 to 98.
And basically when you have only Judas
goats meeting up with other Judas Coats,
then you can say the goats have been
eliminated. You're done a point.
They got to, at least
on Isabella in mid 2006,
uh,
this kind of eradication program was
far beyond anything that anyone had ever
done anywhere in the [inaudible]
because it turns out they weren't just
doing this on Isabella island. No,
we're talking about island by island.
Over the course of about seven years,
they eliminate over 250,000 goats.
[inaudible]
so you, um,
you complete that with
Isabella and did at work.
Yeah. The results of this were absolutely
impressive. You had plants reemerging,
you had trees growing back, and
in a really short period of time,
and this allowed for those
important drip pools and tortoises,
they basically got their home back.
This is the real thing.
Tortoise is walking around
[inaudible] crazy man.
So they did it. They got all
the goats, not all the goats.
What do you mean there's Judas Scouts?
They kept them around. Why? I would just,
I would have shot them first
just out of sympathy for them.
Yeah, exactly. Well, they
needed the goats because, well,
there was the problem of people
[inaudible]
because during the 90s these
demonstrations started.
That happened.
Demonstrations, outrage, violent activity,
constant conflict. To explain
[inaudible] [inaudible]. This is
Augustine Lopez, longtime fisherman,
and he told me that in
the 70s and eighties
[inaudible] lobster was fished all
year round [inaudible] no restrictions.
And then fishermen started making a
killing fishing sea cucumber because there
was this huge demand. But then
the national park comes in,
same group that's doing the
goat eradication and they
tell the fishermen they're
overfishing, the sea cucumber.
They've got to limit their catch.
And the fishermen are like, who are you
to tell me that I can't feed my family?
So they lash out.
They marched down in
Charles Darwin Avenue.
They would come down the street throwing
rocks and sticks and everything.
And that's Paul Watson, founder of
the Sea Shepherd Conservation Society.
He was there counter protesting,
and he says that at one point they went
after national park buildings and they
were attacking the ranger stations with
Molotov cocktails. They blockaded roads.
They literally drove the Rangers out of
the National Park headquarters and took
it over on Isabella. They burned down
a building. They kidnapped some people,
including some of my crew. And they
even killed dozens of tortillas.
It says sledding their throats
according to some accounts.
They even hung them from trees. Uh,
so not only that, but according
to Linda, those goats,
couple islands where they've been
eliminated, fishermen have put them back.
Really? Oh yeah.
And so what they decided to do is leave
the Judas goats on various islands where
they can live out their sterilized
days, chomping on grass,
sharing war stories until such time
as they might be needed again.
[inaudible] this is the war between the
Greens and the and the fisherman and
such. Is that still hot and difficult
and are they still, you know,
killing tortoises and they're
not the fisherman? Um,
they seem to have stopped, you know,
taking over national park and
killing tortoise's. You know, why it,
it's a combination of
reasons. On the one hand,
fishermen have started to participate
in the actual fisheries management more
because it seems like they realize if
they're going to keep their livelihood,
they can't just fish everything
out. But then at the same
time, the tourism economy has been taking
off, and so all of these fishermen,
they find that it's easier for them to
actually survive by using their boats,
um, to take tourists
around island to island.
So they're all kind of converting
over into the tourism economy. Huh.
We're going to take a short
break. This is Radiolab.
We'll be back with producer Tim Howard
and this hour on Galapagos in just a
moment.